good morning hik it's Tuesday so this is
a video about mental illness I think I'm
going to do it in the format actually so
I've had a rough couple months my OCD
and anxiety have been really high and
I've also had this lengthy bout of
depression it started about nine weeks
ago amid really good news actually our
community had this huge win we helped
encourage this company danaher to lower
the price of its tuberculosis tests
which is going to allow five million
more people to be tested for TB every
year it's incredible but when that news
happened I just I felt nothing but dread
it was just this like terrible
Indescribable fear in fact the
Indescribable is part of the problem
right because that's part of what makes
it so difficult to share or to feel
unalone in I can really only approach it
through metaphor or simile it felt like
a blanket of dread just descended
honestly I don't know what else there is
to say about it it just it just kind of
sucks when I was in my 20s there was
some naive part of me that thought if I
could just make it to middle age all of
this would be behind me and that hasn't
turned out to be the case but what is
the case is that even when I can't feel
it I understand intellectually that this
is temporary and that this isn't telling
the full story of what it means to be a
person in the world and I know that if I
just keep pursuing treatment work with
my doctor take my medicine move my body
when I can all that stuff eventually I
will feel different I do think I might
be starting to get better it's been a
little better in last week that's why
I'm able to make a video at all but uh
you know there have been a lot of false
Dawn and you never know speaking of
which let's get a check on the dawn so
it's like too gray and rainy for there
to even be a visible Dawn which you know
as a metaphor is a little bit on the
nose Susan sag described depression as
Melancholy minus its charms which I like
a lot because first it acknowledges the
charms of melancholy like when you're
driving alone at night there's something
sad about it but there's also something
beautiful and lovely about it like when
I feel melancholic there's something
beautiful and Rich and productive about
it whereas when I feel depressed
everything is stolen away except for the
sadness and the weight on my chest I
worry this video is going to suck
because like the thing that it's about
sucks it's just like a piano that's off
key playing one note over and over
despair despair despair but I have to
reject the idea that that tells the
whole story because it just doesn't a
young woman I knew a little Casey
McIntyre just died of cancer she was
married to my friend Andrew Rose Gregory
of the Gregory brothers and she also
worked for many years at the same
publishing house where I published my
books anyway in Le of like flowers at a
memorial service or whatever what she
really wanted to do was erase people's
medical debts one of the many insanities
of the US Health Care system is that so
many people are bankrupted just for
being sick and so Casey wanted to have
this like debt Jubilee and Incredibly
people have raised enough money to
cancel $50 million of medical debt over
the last few days in Casey's memory I'll
put a link in the doo-doo if you want to
join us in donating but what a lovely
way to remember someone and to take care
of each other to be honest with you
sometimes I just hate the world the
hopelessness feels so complete but then
think of all these people coming
together to cancel $50 million in
medical debt in memory of a lovely
person to me that's the complex story of
being a person we cannot save those we
love from suffering as much as we
desperately want to we cannot make life
fair or just but we can reach out to
each other help each other cancel each
other's debts we can be careful of each
other as Philip Larin put it we can be
kind while there is still time Hank I'll
see you on Friday